>> WITCHCRAFT CAN BE A WICKED
THING, JOHN PROCTOR.
>> HE CANNOT HIDE HIS SINS ANY
MORE.
>> HE HAS HIS GOODNESS NOW.
I SHALL NOT TAKE IT FROM HIM.
>> GOD REST HIS SOUL.
♪♪♪
>> OH, HEY.
WE JUST FINISHED OUR HIGH SCHOOL
PERFORMANCE OF "THE CRUCIBLE."
>> AND WE DIDN'T MESS UP AT ALL.
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME TO GET NASTY
AT THE HORNIEST EVENT IN TOWN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S THE CAST PARTY.
>> THIS YEAR IT'S AT
CODY SHUCK'S HOUSE.
>> AND WE'RE GOING TO RIP IT UP
ALL NIGHT UNTIL 11:45.
♪♪♪
♪ GONNA HIT THE PARTY
LIKE I JUST HIT ALL MY CUES
MAKING EYES AT GUYS AS TAN
AS MY CHARACTER SHOES ♪
♪ MY PARENTS GAVE
ME A BOUQUET BUT TONIGHT
I NEED MY HANDS FREE ♪
♪ I'M THE BADDEST BITCH
IN SIGHT WHO PLAYED A
WITCH TONIGHT ♪
♪ I SEE ZACHARY MARCELLI
GONNA HELP HIM GET IT UP
HOPE HE LIKES A SEXY
TEEN IN OLD AGE MAKEUP ♪
♪ GOTTA HIT HIM
WITH THE MOVES
THE MOST RISQUE I KNOW ♪
♪ IT'S THE CHOREOGRAPHY
FROM CHICAGO ♪
♪ ALL AROUND THE ROOM
EVERY BOY WANTS ME
WHICH ONE WILL I CHOOSE
EVERY BOY WANTS A PIECE ♪
♪ AT THE
CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY
CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY ♪
♪ TWENTY FIVE VIRGINS AND
A LOT OF SPRITE AT THE
CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY ♪
♪ GOT MY EYE ON ALEX BARD
WANNA BONE BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW SO I'M GONNA STEAL HIS
HAT FROM HIM ♪
♪ AND JUST SORTA
WALK AROUND
DAMN THIS PARTY'S
OFF THE CHAIN ♪
♪ IT'S THE 10:00 PM
MASSAGE TRAIN ♪
♪ ALL THE LIGHTS
MUST STAY UP
THAT'S THE RULE FROM
CODY'S MOM ♪
♪ MIKEY MAZARINO HAS A
STOLEN CIGARETTE
TAKE A PUFF SO HE CAN SEE
HOW NASTY I CAN GET ♪
♪ THEN I CALL MY MOM AND DAD
AND TELL THEM EVERYTHING
'CAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE ♪
♪ OUR PARENTS' TRUST
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ♪
♪ GRAB THE CUTEST BOY
AND STEAL HIM AWAY
CLOSE AND LOCK THE DOORS ♪
♪ AND WATCH A DVD
OF OUR PLAY ♪
>> WHAT SAY YOU, GOODY PROCTOR?
>> YOU'RE SO GOOD IN THAT SCENE.
>> YOU WERE TOO.
>> OH, UM --
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO NOW?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE WE COULD GO AND GET SOME
PRETZELS?
>> OH.
HECK YEAH.
I LOVE PRETZELS.
♪♪♪
♪ AT THE
CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY
CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY ♪
♪ EVERYBODY COMES
BUT NOBODY NUTS
AT THE CRUCIBLE
CAST PARTY ♪
♪ HEY I'M SENIOR CODY SHUCK
AND YOU ALL ARE IN LUCK
THEY CALL ME
MISTER TRIPLE THREAT ♪
♪ CUZ I CAN DANCE
SING AND [ BLEEP ]E THAT'S WHY
I'M
ALWAYS THE LEAD ♪
♪ THE PARENTS ALL
COME TO SEE ME
I WAS THE PHANTOM
IN PHANTOM ♪
♪ AND I WAS SWEENEY
IN SWEENEY
AND NOW I'M HERE
TO GET FREAKY ♪
♪ SO LADIES
TAKE OFF YOUR TOPS
AND COME OVER AND GET ♪
♪ A SHOW SHIRT
OUT OF THIS BOX
YOUR NAMES ARE LISTED
ALPHABETICAL ♪
♪ INCREDIBLY LEGIBLE
AND IF YOU ARE ON THE CREW
THEN YOU'RE IN
A PARENTHETICAL ♪
♪ I GOT BITCHES
ALL AROUND ME AND THEY'RE
DOWN ON THEIR KNEES ♪
♪ BEGGING WILL YOU
SIGN MY POSTER
FOR MY BEDROOM PLEASE ♪
♪ NOW HERE'S A BIG SECRET
DON'T ASK HOW I KNOW THIS
BUT IF YOU SEX ME RIGHT
TONIGHT I'LL TELL YOU ♪
♪ WHAT THE SPRING SHOW IS
I'LL LAY YOU DOWN ON THE BED
AND WHISPER IN YOUR EAR ♪
♪ THAT MRS. DONAHUE SAID
WE COULD DO RENT THIS YEAR
AND I CAN'T WAIT
FOR REHEARSAL ♪
♪ I'MMA BE IN IT TO WIN IT
WE START IN FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY-FIVE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED MINUTES ♪
♪ OH YEAH
AT THE
CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY
CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY ♪
♪ CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY
CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY
WORKED UP VIRGINS
WHO LOVE TO SING ♪
♪ AT THE
CRUCIBLE CAST PAR-TAY ♪
[ VOCALIZING ]
>> ENOUGH!
>> MOM!
♪ CRUCIBLE CAST PARTY ♪♪♪